Couple of things I want all of you to start playing around with if you can, and
it would be great for you to start doing this on your own if you
have the old Python-OpenCV installation.
And again, we will be providing a browser-based way of doing some of this stuff,
the simpler stuff.
So, you can actually try to do testing of loading images and
stuff like that on your own, within a browser.
But again, we do encourage you to set up a whole platform for
yourselves on your computers so you can start doing some of this on your own.
I would encourage you to play around with these types of things on your own.
On Python basically, or
OpenCV you can import the OpenCV framework by just typing in import cv2.
And you can read input images of any form and also write them out.
And play around and
again, as I said, different aspects of doing these types of things.
In Matlab the same thing is possible.
On what you can basically just read images and you can also write them out.
There are other functions you can play around in Matlab including, for
example, showing the images.
But I encourage you again, to play around and get used to this.
I'm not talking about processing in this lesson here.
But again, there is a lot of documentation available for processing online.
Just a couple other pointers here, you can actually start looking at
the sizes of images, color channels, bits per pixel information.
Again, both in Matlab and in OpenCV Python, there are ways of
being able to do this and seeing what kind of details you can come up with.